we share the same concerns and the same
sorrow for the news we have received
from New Zealand concerning the
terrorist attack against two mosques I
have been in contact with the prime
minister of New Zealand and I have
expressed to the Prime Minister all our
sympathy of condolences and our support
in the difficult moments that the
authorities and the people of the
country are facing and in particular the
need to strengthen our cooperation to
make sure that hate doesn't spread
further in our societies
barbar terror saw drisana that the
anatomical IATA nakai bed another outlet
on rabbit Didier
we are Lara rgeous father leaders in
Israel under Hal Khanna where mr. Manoli
Mina was all the dealers brother ng
disturb Akana Winston Peters the de
Guiche trick2g of rock candy and des
Tech Burma has rolled umezu sorry I
think we all should be united in the
fight against any kind of hate speech or
hate action no matter which religious
belief it is also if it's about ethnic
belongings or sexual orientations there
is no place for this kind of statements
actions expressions